der tag nach der schrecklichen amokfahrt
gestern in berlin ein tag der viele neue
informationen und zeugenaussagen
gebracht hat überraschende tragische zu
den opfern unter ein tag mit einer
womöglich auch entscheidenden wendungen
was die bestrafung des mutmaßlichen
täters betrifft aber und ganz bewusst
beginnen wir mit den leidtragenden
hier haben sie ihre abschlussprüfung
geschrieben den schulstress hinter sich
gebracht in berlin wollten sich die
zehntklässler der realschule bad arolsen
erholen die leichtigkeit der
sommerlichen hauptstadt genießen heute
steht der ort unter schock die türen der
kalbach realschule sind zwar geöffnet an
unterricht ist aber nicht zu denken wir
wollen die schule bewusst offen halten
wir erwarten dass die schülerin schloss
sich austauschen wollen das gilt ebenso
auch für das kollegium dafür haben wir
viele betreuungskräfte hier auch vor ort
von den 24 schülern wurden 14 verletzt
sieben zum teil lebensbedrohlich sie
werden in krankenhäusern behandelt heute
konnten schon einige kinder nach hause
zurückkehren über den tod der lehrerin
tanja h sind schüler lehrer kollegen und
bewohner der region gleichermaßen
schockiert
ja also das kollegium der hand was
zusammen stand tatsächlich unter
schockstarre das war sehr greifbar und
sehr spürbar wenn man sie mit den
kollegen unterhalten hat wir mussten ja
vieles organisieren dann war es vieles
vielen schwer die tränen auch zurück zu
erhalten weil es auch nur eine person
geht die kolleginnen die sie über viele
jahre hinweg ja auch als kollegin haben
schätzen können
tanja h ist zweifache mutter 51 jahre
alt auch bei den nachbarn ist die trauer
groß dort gilt sie als toller mensch
sehr musikalisch und begabt sie war sehr
beliebt nicht nur als lehrerin
und er hat so viel leid verursacht
mutmaßlich bewusst mit vorsatz cora 29
jahre alt nach seiner horror fahrt über
den gehweg an der gedächtniskirche
steigt der deutsch armenier aus ist
unverletzt will weiterlaufen zeugen
halten ihn fest bis die polizei
eintrifft der mann der töten wollte
wimmert dabei vor angeblichen schmerzen
und stammelt um helfer
vorlebt unweit des tatorts das
tatfahrzeug ist auch seine schwester
zugelassen er soll wegen
körperverletzung beleidigung und
hausfriedensbruch
vorbestraft sein als extremist ist er
nicht bekannt der abend spezialkräfte
durchsuchen die wohnung von goya in
charlottenburg sek und lka beamte
stürmen das mehrfamilienhaus rahmen die
wohnungstür im vierten stock auf
sprengstoff oder gefährliche gegenstände
werden nicht gefunden alles deutet jetzt
darauf hin dass cora an einer paranoiden
schizophrenie leidet das teilte die
staatsanwaltschaft mit daher ist die
unterbringung in einer psychiatrischen
anstalt beantragt worden
und das wiederum könnte also dann
bedeuten dass gott ha schult unfähig ist
seine nachbarn den berliner stadtteil
charlottenburg beschreiben ihn als zitat
kleinen runden mann der freundlich grüßt
und nettes und vor dem wohnhaus des
amokfahrers von berlin steht jetzt unser
kollege hannes rawe kann es wie hat der
mann dort gelebt
diese siedlung hier am heckerdamm am
nördlichen ende von charlottenburg auch
dem bezirk wo eben auch der
breitscheidplatz liegt im das ist unweit
des flughafen tegels an denen wird man
sich außerhalb berlins auch noch
erkennen das ist eine klassische
wiederaufbau gegen die es im ende der
1950 er jahre gebaut worden sind
vierstöckige häuser die eben schnell
hochgezogen wurden sie relativ
schmucklos sind wir können wir über
schwenken auf den spielplatz die ist
zwar alles was man braucht wenn man
ausgebombt worden ist aber es ist jetzt
keine wirkliche gegend würden das herz
warm wird wenn man hier wohnt die leute
kennen sich auch untereinander eher
wenig hier in den tee geschossen es ist
es ist ein
bescheidenes zu hause und zu bescheiden
und unauffällig hat er eben hier auch
mit seiner schwester und mit seiner
mutter gelebt seit ungefähr 14 jahren
ist er in berlin und ist deutscher
staatsbürger als eingebürgert worden und
führte eben hier ein sehr unauffälliges
leben wie würdest du das umfeld
beschreiben
unauffällig unspektakulär bescheiden
hier sind leute die morgens arbeiten
gehen die abends nach hause kommen die
es gibt auch keine sommerfest sich hier
dass die nachbarschaft irgendwie
zusammen hält man macht so seins man
grüßt freundlich man geht mit dem hund
in den nahegelegenen jungfernheide park
da soll die familie auch vor allem die
schwester von gahan mit ihm auch sport
gemacht haben oder sie soll vor allem
sport gemacht haben er soll mit gekommen
sein ja aber die leute ist es hier keine
wirkliche gemeinschaft von mietern oder
nachbarn hattest du gelegenheit mit
nachbarn zu sprechen
einige nachbarn haben sich geäußert als
sie mich gesehen haben hier haben gesagt
ja das ist eben unser nachbar wie gesagt
der kleine runde mann
auffällig war dass er nie alleine war
dass er entweder in begleitung seiner
mutter oder seiner schwester war und die
nachbarn haben sich auch gewundert warum
so ein alter mann ja also ein
erwachsener mann überhaupt noch bei
seiner mutter wohnt und da haben sie
sich schon gefragt was was da ist aber
dadurch dass er immer sehr freundlich
gegrüßt hat dass er nie hier im umfeld
aggressiv war wir haben gehört dass es
doch schon einige polizeiliche delikte
eben gegen ihn vorliegen das hat er hier
zu hause nicht ausgelebt das haben also
die nachbarn mit denen ich gesprochen
habe nicht bestätigt seltsam war eben
dass er nie alleine war und das haben
die nachbarn sich eben auch gefragt
was häufig aus berlin vielen dank für
deine informationen handels und die
schreckliche amok fahrt von berlin hat
nicht nur die hauptstadt natürlich in
einen schockzustand versetzt vor allem
die kleine stadt bad arolsen
hessen hat mit dieser
katastrophe muss man sagen zu kämpfen
von dort kamen nämlich eine schulklasse
es war die abschlussfahrt die diese
zehnte klasse nach berlin gemacht hatte
eine lehrerin ist tot unter den vielen
verletzten auch schwer verletzten sind
schüler aus bad arolsen und dort ist
jetzt unser kollege jonathan an der
jonathan levine nimmst du die stimmung
vor ort war was wir doch für die schüler
dort getan
fassungslosigkeit entsetzen schock das
alles hat hier heute den alltag
bestimmen tatsächlich war hier regulärer
schulalltag heute für die schüler dass
der haupt und realschule karlsbach
das war halt tatsächlich auch als hilfe
gedacht weil die schüler so durch diesen
alltag eben eine stütze bekommen sollten
dabei geholfen haben polizisten haben
auch seelsorger aber tatsächlich auch
ein besuch des ministerpräsidenten boris
rhein der sich hier eine lang kollegen
also lehrer kollegen und eltern und
schülern gewidmet hat und zugehört hat
und seine hilfe auch angeboten hat im
sinne eines fonds eines hilfsfonds von
100.000 euro unbürokratische soforthilfe
das todesopfer ist eine lehrerin der
schule wir haben schon gesagt was
konntest du über sie erfahren
sie wohnt in nach bild-informationen
wolfhagen
zusammen mit ihren zwei kindern und soll
auch einen ehemann gehabt haben
wolfhagen ist eine wohngegend mit vielen
einfamilienhäusern
sie soll zwei töchter im teenie-alter
gehabt haben und ja man kennt sich in
wolfhagen wie das eingangs auch
beschrieben war sie war musikal als
musikalisch versiert bekannt
interessiert und war auch hier gegenüber
von der schule beim pizza bäcker ein
immer willkommener gast auch mit
schülern teilweise da gewesen also der
schock über den tod dieser lehrerin
bestimmt hier heute die stimmung
ich habe heute auch ein presse statement
des neuen hessischen ministerpräsidenten
boris rhein was hat er gesagt
ja boris rhein war hier um 11 uhr in der
schule karmann mit dem kultusminister
alexander dort und hat sich eben eine
stunde lang ja allen gewidmet und hat
dann ins presse statement auch gesagt
was er da eigentlich gemacht hat eben
zugehört hat nicht nicht lange geredet
sondern wollte einfach nur da sein und
hat dann aber auch gesagt er würde gerne
dann also ist dann auch gegangen um mit
der begründung das muss man auch alles
also man muss auch den nötigen raum
stellen für für die verkraften für die
verarbeitung und ja so so so hat er sich
geäußert
information von jonathan anderer
ausbaden
ja die stadt die natürlich mit leidet
jetzt mit der verstorbenen lehrerin und
auch mit den schülern die verletzt sind
es war eher klassenausflug ihre
abschlussfahrt nach berlin